Logan 5
all right Logan let's throw efore at
Logan
I would not be surprised if all of our
games up to this point we're just one or
1 minute or hyper bullet
thanks GM Doug's stochastic
the five months in a row man
all right let's let's try in any game
or excuse me a queenless middlegame
and let's just break the pin
here here Knight takes e4 Bishop takes
here
maybe
yeah I could do that because I could
get out of any pin on the e-file with a
check
all right
yeah I'll take him this isn't
this is one of these rare cases where
double isolated ponds are actually
pretty pretty okay
and just solidify the structure I want
my night here this would be a really
good spot for my night in one of the key
16 squares supported by my pond and puts
pressure on one of the weak ponds
so let's uh let's act now we're gonna go
here here here
my other night could look at this
maneuver
let's still go straight in for
okay
with the strike excuse me
also what more do I
do
let's huh I think I want to stop this
idea first and they're probably going to
seek some exchange now
alright well let's make it a little bit
harder for them to kind of untangles
they're really gearing up for b5
I'm cool with this move light square
and I'm going to keep this structure as
is so you could push me away but then I
have this square to work with
here let's get this straight
for I have this kind of maneuver
by keeping this tension I'm a-ok I may
look to do rook a to rook a one and then
force this but they're kind of
committing them a lot sooner so the next
stop for my night here
and they can't they can't count night
here to combat this idea because they
have a responsibility so now now my
pieces are simply falling on really
really nice squares and notice
the structure ties in just perfect with
this guy good versus bad Bishop
situation
you
TECA Gambino what's going on
you
so this all of a sudden becomes very
difficult to defend I mean I could put
all three minor pieces on it let's get
there straight away
right there so I may have
you
you
oh no you can't do this I could take
care
all right so I think I do want to go in
for this manoeuvre
is there something better
actually this move here threatens to
take and then a discovery so I think
this is more direct
okay they kind of just ignored
ix right here so
I can take the bishop
or I could take this pawn first I'm
thinking about this and then here but
what about just taking here first
I think I like this idea
and then sweep my rook in with check and
then pick up in a second pawn actually
thank you to the rug this
for the sub
and everlasting
sponger
and here's the thing my opponent is in a
is in a pickle here
I could double up
and they do this
who cares about that I'm just doubling
up
a night move and I have bishop here
which is a killer three pieces on the
I just got a move
you
I think this just winds now
you
thanks B rug
you
all right what's up Alan and Ches
okay I get to take there with Chuck
you
you know let's just drop my night out of
harm's way
feel like I don't even want to take that
night
you
I want to win that night
just flush them away
let's just mop up stuff
that's a pin
chopping everything now
Oh stalemates
back to tournament lands
you